eyed peas che letti dark di buttare
tutti i dieci in pagella e chi non
studia un boom della tutti i ragazzi
venuti a questi nomi io sono fan ejei
lui e sulle alfa e sentinel fatto sei
quarto sono imbarazzato nel fare video
naro porta gli capita oggi
simpaticamente dopo il raduno di made in
internet ci hanno detto che il nostro
aereo e ben tre ore in ritardo si mia
sorella e lercia e non lo facciamo sul
serio di sbaglia schiaffo in faccia se
in falso io chiave ero ammazzo tutti
cancellati senza chiave che chi sbaglia
schiaffo in faccia forti proprio video
per gli hater i casi che avete aperto il
video perché stato che ci prendono a
schiaffi pezzi di merda un salve signora
che loro è aspettarmi questo non lo so
perché allora non educati ma organi le
parole che ripagano di mouse in
superficie con l'acca quegli episodi ma
il mouse che lo sa la coppa italia e
quest'aspetto dal bianco e un pallone
secondo no non è un pallone ragazzi non
è più un pallone da una cotta coppa alla
coppa ha scelto di una coppa troviamo
una coppa dovrebbe già fune e poi e non
lo dite la vostra ma per me la coppa rio
piano 22 su the man pallone e da ieri
tutti vanno di qua io e il cadrai
affaccino voglia un po chi forte va bene
ma il primo è
cisco me ne faccio il turista domanda
indovina al logo kodak può essere amico
di sicuro qualcosa da questo schiaffo
non sono anche un pò cagato come si
uccide uno orologiaio lasciando handle
me le regole senza neanche leggero ma
ieri segue i commenti sono piste
freddure schifosi
ma se su ritmi tipici del fuoco ti sugli
scali mi sembri scardina non la sapevo e
credito di quale nuovo si tratta enrico
e wicked nemico amico cioè la tavoletta
grafica io e wico cratere gli avrei
detto ichino ma layeni 39 wiki facciamo
così giuliano giorno diceva all'inizio
che sono anche lei forti che manca sono
le nike sul bomber non lo so non le
leggo leggo mail.com per nobili
dovrebbero essere nike credo lo spaf
dice quella di napoli di cuba a vedi con
l'hc di come chi è onesto perché c'è
anche poma poma
no erano line sapevo che hai fatto a
passare a prendere per il culo schiaffo
allo reticenza degenti non avete fatto
male hai fatto il primo è che ma prima
mi vai prossimo un po più di come il
logo delle atomiche sarebbe lato per me
rosso non so cosa sia per me rosso
atomic io dico giallo ma non lo so
semmai il rosso dai due rosse un giallo
invece una serie 3 2 1 l'ultimo questo
va bè ragazzi ha tutta l'aria forchette
a tutela perché dai bastard hyok l'icsim
lo sento come quando si e mosconi è
stata se la scorso ha scritto malissimo
lo sento come quando siamo scoperto che
io loco e figlio ai o no no no non
chiaro chiaro yaris ha parlato di mio
nonno perché non è che il loro è questo
ormai non esiste se come puro
no non esiste ma va mica eravamo della
ra.gi e daje ma scusa ma è una roba
pugliesi ora è in qua sotto infligge il
velo no future a quello che avevano a
perché alla fine così noi di fronte
delle basi e gloria google chrome è il
colore di ville quattro colori dei mesi
che sono aspetta due fa come un panda
corno il pan d'accordo panda corno un
panno quando stanno facendo un vostro
nome
ecco che logo è quello schifo non è
qualche giorno fa nazionale di cinema
come fanno le nozze con un altro noto e
fuck list delle due ultime due può
essere qualsiasi 24 pagine operatori da
hera fai qua a fai te la fai perché c'è
il coso ma la mia parata ci sarà anche
l'ultima anche per un finita dentro di
me ti aspettiamo una biglia lopapa di
roma gli aspetta un pugno
ok perfetto va nov abbiamo scritto no no
dovete dire anche voi
certo io dico a preme coin smash gag e
sarebbe il terzo
siccome il quarto 34 dai ma il 4
vai
era la sua camera solo nagy e aspetta
mentre che vai avanti di riscuotere dai
clandestini e finiamo su video che mi ha
già creato il caos di cioccolata
l'ultima l'ho sbagliata io tanto il
video la mia hobbistica come preparando
la bud spencer la videocamera la stanno
preparando per lo slow motion cosa cosa
magari europei è il momento è con giuda
che mi na li tira tra il giovane genoa
una mina giusta ma si sente il rumore è
un produttore con più iscritti in italia
vale ragazzi che questo video possiamo
concludere qualcosa così onerosa la
ragazza acquistare la messa della luce
ma intanto però così così e così tanto
visto per nintendo miglior acquisto
anche di legno quindi raga storia vi sia
piaciuto come se invece il momento è un
mi piace soprattutto per il rossore è
causato da soli senza questi ed
iscrivetevi ci vediamo nel prossimo
schiappa vari assi
si chiama il più famoso idraulico romano
supermario oscar da bagno no è minore un
po di che colore che era il cavallo
bianco di napoleone
[Musica]